remercié les électeurs comté roberval
qui m'ont indiqué leur confiance ce soir
c'est toujours quelque chose qui nous
remplit de fierté féliciter mes
adversaires dans le comté de roberval
denis trudel thomas gaudreault le
qu'antoine cochon pour leur engagement
envers notre région
un immense merci aux bénévoles et je
peux pas tous et toutes les nommer line
perreault la présidente d'association et
et tous ceux tous ceux et celles qui ont
donné leur bien le plus précieux qui ont
donné le bien le plus précieux qu'ils
doivent tant l'équipe également au parti
à la permanence du cabinet dans les
cabinets qui a travaillé sans relâche à
l'organisation de cette belle campagne
suzanne que toujours été avec copé
toujours à mes côtés à nos fins de
l'autobus
une chance que je l'avais avec moi ça a
été pour moi une source de réconfort
constants mes enfants nos enfants nos
petits-enfants qui inspire notre vision
du québec de demain
tiens aussi à féliciter les jeunes ya
beaucoup de jeunes nouveaux députés de
toutes les formations politiques ce soit
à travers le québec c'est une très très
bonne nouvelle pour le québec et tous eu
également et ou celles qui ont voté pour
la première fois votre engagement est
important continuez à vous battre pour
ce en quoi vous croyez
c'est ce que j'ai toujours fait
également notre solide équipe de
candidats d'être candidat je suis
tellement tellement fiers de vous vous
avez fait une belle campagne
je félicite aussi bien sûr celles et
ceux des autres partis ce soir c'est
clair certains certains éprouvent la
douleur de la défaite et d'autre
l'euphorie de la victoire mais quelle
que soit l'issue de vos batailles vous
avez tous et tout permis au peuple
québécois de poser le geste fondamental
de décider de son avenir
chers militants cher militante le parti
libéral du québec est un grand parti qui
sait être ou 2,20 d'évolution de notre
société depuis 150 ans on sait s'adapter
s'adapter aux nouvelles réalités parfois
même les deux ans et on continuera nous
aussi bien sûr à défendre nos idées nos
valeurs fondamentales
notre vision de la société voilà une de
mes grandes fiertés
je n'ai jamais marchandé mes valeurs et
mes pas
c
ce
pour féliciter le phillies est menacé
par roch à peine de bien sûr des gens de
conviction
ils ont l'occasion de s'adresser avec
monsieur nadeau dubois qu'on a vu tantôt
aux québécois et bien sûr je veux
féliciter monsieur legault pour sa
victoire qui est bien sûr net sans
ambiguïté les québécois et québécoises
ont clairement indiqué un désir de
changement
il lui revient maintenant avec son
équipe de poursuivre l'élan du québec
les assurer de mon entière collaboration
et qui ainsi que de celle de mon équipe
pour faciliter la transition
je souhaite à son gouvernement tout le
succès que le québec mérite calme malgré
nos différences d'opinion significative
nous sommes tous québécois tous et
toutes
on doit rester uni on est plus forts
unis ce soir comme à chaque élection la
population bien sûr a fait un choix
en politique il faut savoir goûter les
joies de la victoire et accepter la
défaite car elles sont les deux facettes
de la démocratie je suis pas amer je
vous demande de ne pas l'être
je suis fier vous pouvez l'être aussi
c'est fou ce fut sans contredit le plus
grand honneur de ma vie professionnelle
de servir les québécois et les
québécoises à titre de premier ministre
j'ai rempli mon mandat au meilleur de ma
compétence avec toute mon énergie
j'ai servi les québécoises et les
québécois avec tout mon coeur comme nous
tous j'aime profondément de notre québec
en quatre ans nous allons redonner au
québec la liberté de choix les progrès
que nous avons accomplis sont
remarquables on s'en souviendra je crois
aujourd'hui le québec paie un milliard
de moins en intérêts aux banques
étrangères un milliard de moins un média
qu'on investit dans nos services publics
dans nos écoles nos hôpitaux
on cherche plus d emplois
on cherche des travailleurs nos finances
publiques sont saines et solides et pour
longtemps pour longtemps nous avons des
marges et des moyens
l'idée le québec que durant cette
transformation avec une équipe
formidable a été un parcours
extraordinaire
et oui on a fait ce qu'on avait dit
qu'on ferait souvenons nous aussi
ensemble
ensemble on le fait ce qu'il fallait
faire on a jeté les bases pour faire du
québec un québec plus prospère plus
juste et plus vers un québec qui est
maintenant regarder avec respect et même
admiration sur les plans économique
culturel social et environnemental au
québec d'entre eux tous et toutes être
fier je termine donc mon mandat de
premier ministre la tête très haute
jeunesse je laisse le québec croyez moi
à bien meilleur état que je les trouvais
en 2014
je suis fier de nos accomplissements
confiant en l'avenir qu'on a préféré
convaincu que notre engagement est le
bon ce soir chaque boîte à compter à
partir de demain et pour tous les jours
qui suivront chaque voix contre
l'élection c'est un moyen c'est pas une
fin cet engagement et pour le québec
pour tous les québécois et tous les
québécoises de toutes les origines qui
forment un seul peuple pour une vision
ouverte inclusive moderne de notre
société pour l'avenir
thomas reynaud english speaking comme
accusant tous ses amis constitueraient
casse à la fin je veux dire que vous
êtes des citoyens de première classe
rester chez nous construisez le québec
avec tous les québécois
oui le français est notre langue
officielle mais l'anglais n'est pas une
langue étrangère
vous avez toujours été parmi nous avait
fait partie de nous vous faites partie
de notre histoire
le choix de la population
il est clair qu'à titre de chef de notre
parti je dois accepter la responsabilité
du résultat de ce soir je devrais donc
entreprendre une réflexion sur mon
avenir personnel afin de réduire la
période d'instabilité qui en résultera
cette réflexion sera courte quelques
jours au maximum
chers amis je vous laisse sur ces mots
un parti ou un gouvernement ne peuvent
prétendre de fabriquer l'avenir plutôt à
façonner aujourd'hui la société qui le
fera en lui donnant les moyens de ses
rêves
j'ai confiance en notre avenir j'ai
confiance en québec
j'ai confiance en notre peuple qui est
beau et fort merci bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]